Парк створено 2002 року.
Оскільки тут військові полігони,
територія виселена.
Отже, це сприяло тому,
що багато рідкісних видів
і рослин, і тварин збереглося.
І було вирішено тут створити парк.
Тільки створили 2002 року,
він фактично існував як додаток
до приватного мисливського господарства.
І все почалося приблизно з 2006 року.
Якраз я сюди прийшов 2006 року.
Теж прийшов з мисливського господарства.
У мене було розуміння своєї роботи,
що основний показник нашої роботи —
це кількість складених протоколів
на порушників якихось правил полювання тощо.
Місцеві сприймали парк
як винятково шкідливу організацію,
яка не дає ловити рибу,
не дає стріляти тощо.
У нас тоді вдавалося знайти гроші,
то люди носили форму.
Постійно ж зі зброєю,
нас плутали з мисливськими господарствами, з єгерями.
А потім, з 2009 року почали
приймати екскурсії, водити тури.
З'ясувалося, що це цікавіше,
та й парку це більше личить.
Так 2009 року почали,
а 2010 року зробили першу екостежку.
Ось цю екостежку зробили минулого року.
[показує]
2012 року побудували офісне приміщення,
2013 року — музей.
Так воно потихеньку розвивається.
Минулого року створили цю екостежку —
Бондарівське болото.
А іноді люди неправильно читають
як Бандерівське. [сміється]
Але загалом це теж нормально.
Люди часто думають, що болото —
це має бути стояча вода, ряска й очерет.
То вони при цьому уявляють не болото, а водойми.
На болоті відкритої води може не бути взагалі.
Тобто якщо ранньою весною сюди прийти,
видно, що трава лежить після зими,
окремі купини [рослини, що ростуть на болотах],
і все залите водою,
воно дійсно виглядає тоді красиво.
Тут попід містками вода.
Оці зарості — це хвощ болотяний.
Він такий гарний,
трубчастий, наче бамбук.
Він дуже жорсткий, у нього є скелет з кремнезему
[один із мінералів кремнію].
То його не їсть жодна копитна тварина.
Людина використовувала його в такий спосіб:
якщо його зібрати в пучечок,
то ним раніше мили дерев'яний посуд.
Він як дрібний наждак відшліфовує посуд.
Тут дуже гарні були квіти,
але вже відцвіли.
Ще тиждень тому вони цвіли,
це півники сибірські, червонокнижні рослини.
Ну вже ж квітів не лишилось,
буквально дві квіточки.
Коли воно все цвіло,
тоді, звичайно, було класно.
У нас безліч червонокнижних видів,
понад 100.
Часто люди так вважають,
що як можуть природно-заповідний фонд
і полігони вживатися на одній території?
Є величезна площа,
на яку людей зайвий раз не пускають,
іноді там проводять стрільби.
На полігонах безліч рідкісних рослин.
Під полігони повиселяли села якраз.
А що означає, що виселили село?
Це ж не лише село прибрали,
це всі випаси, вигони, поля, сінокоси.
Все, що було навколо села, одразу
починає заростати лісом у нашій місцевості.
І місцевість дичавіє, тобто для тварин,
навпаки, тільки краще зробили.
Коли проводиш екскурсію,
то краще спрацьовує не ця стежка,
а стара, яку зробили раніше,
там, де є речі, які можна помацати руками,
біля них сфотографуватись.
Наприклад: реконструкція язичницького капища,
відбудований ДЗОТ [дерево-земляна оборонна точка],
місточок красивий, щоб людина могла
стати поруч, сфотографуватися.
Це більш цікаво людям.
Річ у тім, що там, де є можливість,
бобер копає нори з-під води.
А там, де берег низький,
то він вимушений будувати хатки.
Тобто він натягує купу хмизу, гілок, землі
і вигризає зубами собі вхід та житлове приміщення.
Так, як ось тут показано,
або ж як на малюнку.
Єдине, що тут вода зараз занадто висохла,
оскільки літо у нас сухе досить,
бо дощів мало.
То вхід в хатку не підтоплений,
для бобра це погано.
Це ми зараз виходимо на територію так званих
(як по-народному зветься) борів-біломошників,
тобто досить рідкісні угрупування.
Тут ось все вкрито далі кладонією оленячою,
або по-народному просто — білим мохом.
Він витоптування, щоправда, дуже боїться,
по сухій погоді він дуже легко розсипається,
якщо на нього наступити, та здається неживим.
А якщо в вологу погоду сюди прийти,
то він буде м'яким, пружним, як губка.
Це такі угрупування, притаманні тайзі,
в Україні їх мало, особливо щоб такі
великі площі було вкрито сірим лишайником.
Чутно, наче ми йдемо по сухому печиву.
Лось обдирає кору,
зубами він шкрябає кору,
і [з'являються] ось такі пошкодження.
Його не люблять лісівники через це.
Тому що дерева, погризені лосем,
не пропадуть, вони-то виживуть,
але зазвичай вони ростуть більш кострубатими,
і з них не отримаєш ділової деревини.
Тут ось зимою паслися лосі,
видно, що [залишився] послід,
він такий довгенький у самця, більш квадратний.
Він сухий, чистий, руки не забруднює,
дітям можна підсовувати
і казати, що це жолуді.
Їх беруть в руки, вони дійсно
дуже тверді, майже дерев'яні.
Їх люди збирають, вкривають лаком
та роблять жартівливе намисто.
Такого добра тут багато.
Усе частіше ловляться на полюванні
люди без здобичі,
але, так би мовити, з намірами.
Якщо перебуваєш в угіддях зі зброєю,
це вже вважається полюванням,
це вже теж є порушенням,
за яке передбачено покарання.
Виходить, такий будиночок,
всередині тут [можна] сидіти,
наприклад, звідти болото добре проглядається.
Якщо ранньою весною сюди прийти,
то тут можна й журавлів побачити.
Причому, тут вони не тільки пасуться,
а й шлюбні ігри влаштовують.
У них вони досить красиві.
За тими ж бекасами [невеликі
прибережні птахи] поспостерігати...
Буває, якщо пощастить і тихенько собі сидіти,
то можна й того ж лося зустріти.
Тут лосиха з двома лосенятами всю зиму
трималась навколо цієї бесідки.
Вони тут пооб'їдали всі кущі.
Зазвичай в організованих груп,
які потрапляють сюди з туристичними фірмами,
ось тут закінчується екскурсія
посеред дня обідом,
бо тут в бесідці місця якраз достатньо.
У вологіших місцях береза
понаростала, досить густа.
Такий цікавий теж пейзаж,
досить веселі такі ліси.
Березняки світлі,
багато світла пропускають до землі.
Тому й трава тут добре так розрослась.
Зручні місця для відпочинку, приємні.
Спочатку [у жителів] ставлення
було переважно негативним.
А після того, як зробили цей музей,
при відкритті музею запросили
все село на таку невелику гулянку.
Тоді й місцевий фольклорний колектив приїхав.
Вони там гарно співали.
Діти розповідали вірші.
А далі ми накрили стіл для всього села.
Був куліш і якась випивка.
Але після цього ставлення змінилося,
люди почали щось приносити для музею.
Тобто зрозуміли, що ми не якась шкідлива організація.
Плюс коли до нас частіше почали їздити туристи
(а зараз це практично кожні вихідні),
то виходить так, що місцеві можуть
молоко продати, сухі гриби тощо.
То вони розуміють, що парк —
корисна організація загалом.
Людей потрібно спонукати охороняти
природу саме через такі моменти,
бо це впливає більш надійно,
ніж щось забороняти чи критикувати.